لقد انتقلت إليها كثيرًا في الواقع ، لقد
أخرجتها من متجر الأثاث ،
وأرادت الحصول على بعض الأثاث ، وسأريك
بعض الأثاث الجميل [
الموسيقى]
الذي يظهر لك في هذا الفيديو بشكل صحيح ، نعم
حسنًا وأنت تعرف ما قلته بعد ذلك
وأقول الآن إنه حديث غرفة خلع الملابس كان حديثًا في
غرفة خلع الملابس ، حسنًا ،
لذا استمر [
موسيقى] ،
شكرًا لك [
موسيقى] لقد
قلت في الفيديو الذي اقتبسته من مقاطع الفيديو التي
اقتبستها ، انتقلت إليها ، عذرًا قلت
في الفيديو إنك
انتقل اقتباس أو هل قلت ذلك مرة أخرى
وأنت تقول في الفيديو إن هذا جزء
من محاولة ممارسة الجنس مع هذه المرأة ، لقد
أخذت أثاثها بشكل صحيح ، لقد
بحثنا بالفعل عن أثاث
أجنبي
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنها مريضة عقليًا  مرة أخرى
عندما تقول إنك تقول الضجيج ، فأنت تشير إلى
النظر إلى الصور ، لذا فأنت
جسديًا ليست من نوعي ، والآن بعد أن
سمعت بشكل غير مباشر
أشياء عنها ، لن تكون من نوعي
بأي شكل من الأشكال أو الشكل.  علينا
استخدام بعضها فقط في حال
بدأت في تقبيلها ،
أنت تعلم أنني منجذبة تلقائيًا إلى
الجمال ، بدأت للتو في تقبيلهم ، إنه
مثل المغناطيس
لا أحتاج إلى الانتظار وعندما تكون
نجمًا يسمحون لك بفعل ذلك  يمكن أن تفعل
أي شيء
أجنبي